hey everyone
my name is Mitchell I'm a machine
learning engineer at comma and I'm going
to talk a bit today about all the work
we've done to ship navigate on open
pilot
so this is a project we've been working
on for a while
I think I started on this late last year
and then we showed off an initial
version of navigate in our driving to
Taco Bell video at the end of last year
uh the idea
is
well the driving model already takes the
videos from the two cameras on the comma
3 as inputs so
we're just going to add a third input
that's a video of Google Maps and this
should just work right
so the great thing about training our
model end to end is we should just be
able to pass the map in as an input
and since the model is trying to predict
where a human would drive
and the map has a lot of useful
information about where the the human is
going to drive the model should just
figure this out it should learn to use
the map figure out where you're going to
go when to take exits when to make turns
and generally do whatever Maneuvers are
necessary to follow the route and get
you to your destination
so this is what we built and it works
pretty well so I'm going to talk a bit
today about how all of this works all
the little details that make it work
better and all of the work we've done to
validate this feature and get it ready
to ship for openpilot 094
so I'll start with how it works
the first thing we're going to need if
we want to build this is a good map
so
fortunately there's a lot of really good
open source tooling we can take
advantage of here uh
open street maps overpass to serve up
sections of the osm graph Valhalla for
routing mapbox Geo to render the maps
all of these tools have been really
useful in building this
so
we need Maps
we train our driving models on a large
data set of 60 second video clips so
we're going to need maps for all of
those video clips
and again the good news is open pilot
already has navigation the comma 3
launched with built-in nav using the
mapbox geonative library
and so we can just use this same library
in our data center and we can render as
many Maps as we want
mapbox GL is pretty nice you give it a
lot latitude longitude coordinate you
give it a route and it will render a map
for you so you can see this at work here
an open pilot and we're going to reuse
this same system
these are the maps we're going to draw
they're intentionally styled to be very
Bare Bones we just draw the road in
white the route to follow in Gray
and we just draw these as uh 256 by 256
pixel images
two pixels per meter so this is a half a
kilometer on each side
and these maps are nice and simple and
easy to reason about
so we want to render a lot of these Maps
and like I said we need two things we
need the latitude longitude for each map
and we need a route
so the latitude longitude is easy enough
the comma 3 has a built-in GPS so we can
just get the GPS coordinates from that
the route is a little bit trickier
so
you can see here a visualization of a
little chunk of the openstreetmaps graph
the Junctions are marked in blue and we
have some GPS measurements from a comma
three
marked in green with the X's
and you can see here that the GPS
measurements don't line up exactly with
the road
so they can be shifted a little bit they
can be noisy for lots of reasons the GPS
measurements may not line up exactly
with the openstreetmaps graph so we need
to fix this to get a route what we want
to do is take a list of all of the GPS
measurements from one of these video
clips and we want to figure out which
roads were actually driven on in that
video clip we want to match these GPS
points up with your clip to the osm
graph and then we want to snap those GPS
points to the right roads
so fortunately we do not have to do this
ourselves this is somewhat complicated
to implement
um but there's lots of services that'll
do it uh mapbox has an API for it but
there's also an open source routing
engine called Valhalla that does exactly
this this is called map matching so you
give it a list of these GPS points
and it turns it into a proper route
marked in red snapping all of the points
to the graph and giving you the exact
route that you drove
so this is exactly what we want we've
got our long coordinates we've got our
route and now we can draw our Maps
so now that we have our Maps
we just need to feed them into the
driving model somehow
the problem is uh on their own the raw
maps are 256 by 256 pixels so that's
like 65 000 numbers that's way too big
so we can't feed these directly into the
model
uh we're gonna have to squish them down
somehow to make them a little bit easier
to work with
so how are we going to do this
well
we already do this for the camera images
those have the exact same problem so we
have a neural network running on the
comma three that takes in a frame
from the cameras
and compresses it down into a vector of
numbers this is called a feature vector
and this Vector should represent all of
the details of the scene that are
relevant for driving
so this is about 2 000 numbers for every
frame of the video and these get passed
into the driving model so we want to do
something similar for the map model
we want to train some kind of neural
network that's going to take in the map
it's going to compress it down into a
vector that has all the information the
driving model needs
and then we'll pass that to the driving
model
so the way we're going to train this map
model is as what's called an auto
encoder
so what this means
is that the neural network is going to
have two parts an encoder and a decoder
so we're going to feed these maps that
we render into the encoder and the
encoder is going to squish these Maps
down into this little feature Vector of
a couple hundred numbers and then the
decoder is going to take those numbers
and try to get back to the original
image it's going to decompress it and
try to get as close as possible to what
we originally put in
and if we train this all correctly
this feature vector
should be a complete representation of
the full image it should have all of the
details of the map that the driving
model needs to know about
so
we train this thing
and then we can just throw away the
decoder we don't need that we just need
the encoder
the encoder gives us some features and
we just feed those features into the
driving model
so now we've got our nice squish down
format we can generate these map
features
and you can kind of see here what the
autoencoder is doing so on the left we
can see the original maps that we render
with mapbox GL
and then on the right you can see these
Maps after being squished and then
decompressed by the neural network
you can see a little bit of detail is
lost it's not a perfect reconstruction
but it does a pretty good job at
capturing all the high level details and
all of the information about the map
that's necessary for the driving model
to figure out where to go
so now we've got our Maps we've got our
map features
and all that's left to do
is hook this thing up to our simulator
that Harold talked about
train a model with it
and cross our fingers that we did
everything right and this will just work
so we do this
and
it works pretty well
so you can see here these are some
videos from our Simulator the model's
predicted path is in Orange and the real
path driven by the human is in blue so
you can see as the model gets close to
the exits uh its prediction moves over
the model switches its trajectory to
take the exit and follow the route just
like it's supposed to so this is great
we can do the same thing for turns
you see here the model does a pretty
good job as it gets close to the turn it
adjusts its prediction so that it's
going to try to follow the route
so this is fantastic we have
a driving model that's going to try to
follow the route that we give it from
the map and now we just have to run this
on the comma 3.
so
fortunately this part isn't isn't too
complicated
we're going to add a few new processes
to open pilot that'll let us do all of
this stuff
uh so we'll add a process called Maps D
at a process called nav Model D uh Maps
D is going to render our maps for us
using mapbox GL native
and nav Model D is going to take those
Maps run them through our encoder and
get our mapped features out
and then we just need to make a little
change to Model D which runs the main
driving model
we'll just make a change so it takes in
those map features from nav Model D it
passes them into the driving model as a
new input
and then everything else works just like
before
so we do all of this we put it on a
branch
and it works you can see openpilot is
taking an exit here following the route
on the right
and uh
if we've done everything right this all
just works it works pretty well
so
to give you a sense of perspective this
is roughly where things stood for the
Taco Bell video
at the end of last year
so we've been working a lot since then
to get this ready to ship it always
seems to take longer to actually get
things deployed and test all of the edge
cases than it did to build it in the
first place
so
I'll talk a little now about exactly uh
what it took to ship and specifically
some of the details uh that you have to
get right to make this all work better
and uh some some details that uncovered
some bugs
so
one obvious problem that you run into
right away when you're building this
stuff
is that
if you look at Google Maps or Bing Maps
or any of these online maps and you just
pan up and down you'll see that the
scale at the bottom right of the map is
changing
it changes from 500 miles in the middle
of the U.S all the way down to 200 miles
for the same length at the Northern end
of Canada
and the reason this happens
is because the Earth is a sphere and
maps are rectangular and so you have to
take a spherical globe and somehow
project it onto a rectangular map and
you can't do that perfectly you have to
make some compromises so the way that uh
most Maps these days do this is with
something called a Mercator Projection
so the Mercator Projection keeps these
nice straight latitude and longitude
lines but the problem with this is that
the areas near the North and South Pole
get way blown up
um
so you can see this happening here and
for humans this isn't really that big of
a problem
but for a driving model this is a little
bit inconvenient because this model is
going to use the map to predict in 3D
space where it's going to drive
so without any extra information the
model doesn't know if it's making a turn
in 200 meters or 500 meters because this
the scale of the map could be totally
different
so we need to take care of this uh it's
not too difficult we can just
dynamically adjust the zoom level of the
map to get a constant scale so like I
said before we're going to render our
maps at a scale of half a kilometer on
each side and we'll change the zoom
level as necessary to make that happen
another problem we run into is that
well we did all of this work to make
sure that our routes were accurate to
the road that were actually driven in
each video clip but we actually did too
good a job and so the problem is that
sometimes when you're driving with your
commentary
you maybe miss a turn maybe you missed
an exit or sometimes you just don't want
to follow the nav instructions maybe you
think mapbox is telling you to do the
wrong thing and so you just do something
else
and the problem here is that with the
way we've trained this model so far it's
basically never seen a wrong turn before
so the model is going to get super
confused if you miss an exit it might
try to take an uncommitted Lane change
or it might try to break in the middle
of the highway all of these things are
really bad so we can't have this we got
to fix it
um so there's a couple different things
that you can try that we've tried uh but
what seems to work pretty well is we can
uh generate these artificial routes that
essentially have wrong turns in them we
can uh take the open street maps graph
we already know exactly what route was
driven in red
and so we can just pick one of the
Junctions in the video
go off in a different direction and then
do a random walk of the graph from there
to generate these artificial routes
and we can train on a small percentage
of these to make the model more robust
so there is a bit of a trade-off here
this is a delicate balancing act because
if you train on too many of these the
model will learn that sometimes it
shouldn't follow the route and so it
won't be as diligent about doing the
right thing and trying to follow the
route when it can
but if you don't train on enough the
model won't be robust and it can have
bad behavior so you have to balance
these two things out and we've found
that uh training on roughly five to ten
percent fake routes uh maintains a good
compromise between making the model
robust while also not harming its
performance at taking exits and turns
so now we
have our model we've fixed some bugs and
the last thing we have to do to get it
ready to ship is write and a ton of
tests we want to validate this behavior
in all of the cases we can think of in a
bunch of edge cases and we want to know
exactly what these models are going to
do when we deploy them
so like Good Deed was saying
we have a saying at comma
that goes no testing in cars
and the reason for this is especially
for research
um
even though what we ultimately care
about is that the model drives the car
well
we don't want to test our models by
putting them on an open pilot branch and
seeing what happens this is way too slow
uh
if we if we have a model that we think
maybe we'll be good we don't really know
so we put it on an open pilot Branch we
let some people drive on it we drive on
it ourselves We Gather a sample of data
and then maybe it turns out our model
had a subtle bug in it and now we've
just wasted days or even weeks waiting
for this data to come back so we can
evaluate so this is a huge waste of time
and so our rule because of this is no
testing in cars
instead we try to write as many offline
tests as possible so before we ever put
this on an open pilot Branch we want to
have a pretty good idea of how it's
going to behave when we do it
so these offline tests can take a lot of
different forms we can test by running
the model on real driving data and
seeing what it does we can test the
model in our simulator we can test them
in more traditional simulators like
Carla or GTA we can run a bunch of
different tests in different cases and
see exactly how this thing is going to
perform so
what should we test for
well there's a few obvious ones we want
to make sure that the model takes exits
when the route says to take the exit
so we can test that in our simulator I
showed some videos from that exact test
earlier
um we want to make sure that the
model doesn't take exits when it's not
supposed to
we want to make sure it takes turns when
it's supposed to doesn't take turns when
it's not supposed to we want to make
sure the model doesn't misbehave if the
route is incorrect if you miss a turn or
an exit if the GPS location is a little
bit wrong and it snaps you to the wrong
road we want to make sure
that it doesn't misbehave if the bearing
is inaccurate so the map is like pointed
the wrong way a little bit
we want to make sure
that the driving behavior doesn't
regress at all when you're not using nav
because we're just shipping nav in
experimental mode right now and so if
you're driving in chill mode we really
want to make sure that behavior doesn't
regress in any way and if anything it
gets a little bit better
uh and we want to make sure that
the behavior of these nav models is the
same when we run them on the comma 3.
compared to when we run them offline
so we do all these tests plus a bunch
more tests we've spent the last few
months just writing test test tests and
validating all the behavior we can think
of lots of different edge cases and
making sure that these models behave
exactly the way we want
so we've
finally written enough tests
to
give us the the confidence to ship this
for openpilot094 and you can try it out
today it's available in experimental
mode and as we keep working on
navigation and we drive the reliability
up to 100 we hope to ship it in chill
mode as well so it'll be available for
everyone that uses open pilot with Prime
so
that's my talk
[Applause]
I'm gonna give time for a few questions
all right
Jason over here
I wonder if you could talk for a second
about how speed limits figure in that
you get from the maps I know that you
want the end-to-end model to function as
independently as possible you don't want
to depend on map data but do you foresee
a future and using that as an input more
consistently especially when not
navigating I'm given to understand the
mapbox API doesn't really lend itself to
giving you speed limits uh if you're not
navigating but I think there was some
sort of way around that with the real
house or I don't know much about it and
I guess my question is really
long term do you see that as an input or
a hint into the into the overall driving
long term I think probably yes
um
right now there's a lot of situations uh
where the
longitudinal Behavior still isn't
perfect that has nothing to do with
speed limits so we want to fix that
first like if you're driving on a
highway and the model is only driving 55
you shouldn't need speed limits to know
it's driving the wrong speeds so we want
to fix that behavior first
um and uh like you say my boxes API is
not super conducive to uh giving you the
speed limits there's a lot of areas
where speed limits just aren't even
available
but long term I think there's a lot of
cases where you can't really tell how
fast you're supposed to be driving
without the speed limit so I imagine we
will eventually need to add this as a
model input yes
all right got a question in the back
along the same lines any
um thoughts on future input for
real-time traffic that would then allow
for you know changing of routes
um
sort of so mapbox already takes care of
this it has its own uh traffic tracking
system
and so ideally the routes that go into
the map in the first place should
already take into account the traffic
now map boxes uh traffic uh system is is
not perfect uh and it does sometimes uh
over underestimate the amount of traffic
in a particular area but hopefully this
is something that'll improve over time
uh hey have you put in any thought into
like text-based navigation using like I
can see from your navigation that you
have like take the next exit for example
like do you guys use that as inputs ever
yes so
we have a branch right now that uh
hopefully will ship for open pilot 095
after some more testing and validation
that puts not just the map but also the
nav instructions into the model uh and
we find that this uh reduces the uh the
failure rate of the model to to take
exits and turns even further so yes this
will probably be coming to a comma 3
near you sometime soon
oh thank you for your presentation
um I just have a question have you ever
considered using Vector Maps instead of
this rendered Maps could you say again
have you ever considered using Vector
Maps instead of the render be way map ah
um
yes so we do get the vector tiles back
from mapbox directly and so we could
consider using those and there are some
advantages to that in that uh there's
there can be a bit of ambiguity just
with the rasterized maps in some cases
where you have a lot of roads really
close together so this is something we
may look into in the future
map boxes tools kind of make it easiest
to just render a map normally and then
you can just use a normal confnet
efficient net to uh to process this and
compress it with Vector based Maps maybe
you'd want something more like like a
graph neural net and these are a little
bit more complex and so we wanted to
start with the simplest thing that could
possibly work but maybe this is
something we'll look at in the future
uh I use this uh navigation feature like
uh
a few days ago
and I found a problem when I uh used it
that it works for the first maybe a
minute and then it's just a quit by
itself uh any explanation on that I'm
not sure we'll have to look at your logs
and maybe this I can I can get your
information afterwards and we'll see if
something weird is going on all right
another another question is
um uh have you ever thought about using
the map for for the uh just the uh to
the very original input maybe map it to
the perspective view together with uh
with the with the image oh yeah
um
so the auto encoder we trained uh
actually also predicts the trajectory
that you're gonna take
um
in addition to uh just compressing the
map it tries to uh predict in 3D space
where you're going to drive and so we
could
uh potentially use some of these
additional outputs to show extra
information on the driving view but this
is not a super high priority right now
this is something maybe we look at in
the future as you know the main
functionality of nav gets better and we
have time to think about some cool
additional features
for the map encoder is it trained
primarily on a reconstruction loss or is
it trained jointly with the driving
model so it can more intelligently like
select which features I report to
uh it's trained separately we do this
for a couple reasons uh one because
uh we want to run this model on the DSP
instead of on the GPU
and so the map model has to be quantized
and so we train it uh with the
quantization aware hooks in pytorch
without this it doesn't really work
properly and so in that sense it sort of
has to be uh
trained as a separate model
and then also training full confidence
with the SIM is a lot of compute and so
it's a little bit easier to split it up
we have looked at doing it jointly as
well either with the vision model or
with the policy model
but the autoencoder does do a pretty
good job of capturing the all of the
details of the map and so for now at
least we think that it is probably doing
just fine to just compress it to this
feature vector and then have the driving
model process it from there we've got
one last question here
so when you started uh the talk you
talked about how you you know at first
wanted to just feed the video data of
the of the directions into the model and
hopefully it would work and then it
worked pretty well but I would think
there's like kind of an inherent
conflict between the original video
input and the the map like the
directions input are is does the model
just synthesize those two like magically
or do you have to really like weight
them or like try to give inputs on which
input is the you know the the primary to
follow or how does that work in the
model
you're talking about uh resolving like
the video coming in with the map yeah
the idea that the video tells you know
one set of sort of inputs on how you
should direct the you know the deriving
output versus the map now suddenly you
might say you know actually I want to go
this way so I kind of feel like the two
different pieces piece of information
might give different outputs how do you
how do you train the model to know which
one to follow and which in what
circumstances sir
so this is exactly part of the reason
that we train on uh some percentage of
these fake routes we want to make the
model robust to maps that either tell it
to do the wrong thing or don't make any
sense uh and so when we always want to
trust the video because the video is
always right or at least it better be uh
whereas the map could be wrong for any
number of reasons
um and so we uh do a bunch of stuff when
we train these models to try to make
them more robust to failures of the map
uh if the route suddenly goes out or GPS
suddenly goes out or any number of uh
things that might happen road closures
uh taking a wrong turn all this stuff so
we really wanted to trust the video more
than the map
all right thank you so much Mitchell
[Applause]